you
less than 10 the Gunzburg tournaments at
3 Oh time control some blitz chess 55
minute tournaments around one against
farmville let's throw let's throw the
caro-kann at farmville and see what he
does
uh-huh
all right let's try Queen d5 I'm just
looking to get my bishop out
they want none of that already
Bishop blocks and what do we do here hmm
wasting a lot of time
let's try that oh really
I was expecting Queen b3 to keep the
Queen's on the board
I'm just trying for this now
and I'm trying to Castle queenside clear
this out and Queen B 3 and I'm actually
struggling because there's gonna be this
pawn break let's see what a white does
here actually another thing is you need
to be a bit careful my bishop may be
being trapped let's do this first on f4
maybe I do this maybe even this one
first
yeah it's definitely a bit tricky
how's this beep undefended Jeep on sharp
position f4 is combating my idea to
challenge the bishop bishop g6 f5 ok can
I not just take that pond might be down
the exchange at some point
hmm I might need to do that
I'm going to go for it
he might end up getting trapped yeah is
that what's gonna happen he's just gonna
be trapped might have to try to play
this with the two bishops and have a
pond starting to seem like that
yeah Bishop e4 he's pretty short on
squares all right let's go here mm-hmm
I guess I have to give him back now okay
let's see what we could do with this
need to get castled really soon he's
close to being trapped as well and he
will be trapped mmm being down a full
rook is no good and I believe that
that's what's gonna happen I gotta try
this only way to escape I guess yeah at
least I could go here taking away all
the squares by my bishop serious time
disadvantage as well not necessarily
even threaten to take that night he runs
the risk of being trapped again
Knight f6 could try to coordinate on the
light squares but this is probably
busted huh and I worked - III that's my
only move let's see what we could do
with this position not very good I could
try to converge on this pawn here on f5
that's about it this is really
short-lived pressure
actually I'm threatening night here rook
up to down a bunch of pawns as well
though no not a bunch one pond catching
up on the clock some I wanna get my
knight here it's kind of
position locked some rook takes pawn is
maybe a threat looking for b5 next I
have a strong night that's about it
catching up on the clocks um they're
gonna put you putting pressure on this
pond mm don't you try this that's a
pretty pretty big dummy move maybe see
five in here I have a night check their
rut can't move either it comes with some
cost yeah I got to try to get active
over here now
not really working
they had a pond push yeah yeah you know
this is this is dusted off
I don't have anything I haven't had
anything for some time many ways to win
this I am in a giant pickle no time to
design oh I thought had some hope when
my clock was kind of evening out but mmm
poor game to start played well my bishop
is was trapped I didn't quite manage
that Bishop g6 with f4 was a very nice
move all right let's get back on the
horse let's try efore against Heiser see
what he throws at me
Scandinavian okay let's go in Knight c3
hmm all the way back home let's go
Bishop c4 and
g4 is a blunder because of 95 I'll stay
on this diagonal try to make something
happen
against f7 let's keep canceling option
open let's focus on f7 a little bit okay
you're gonna get that pawn back could
challenge him right away Bishop to e3 a
slight full for me development wise I
think yeah just a hair balance material
now I guess they could consider Bishop
d6 let's see 218 all right we'll take
let's try to peel this open some my
Bishop really doesn't stand well maybe
he does know I'm doing this because I
want to have some target in that of the
a6 pawn all right let's get on this
diagonal I want to get my King involved
right around this point I'm thinking of
king improvement f4 f3 I'm not sure
probably f3 a bit more conservative
watch over these possible squares I
think this is a fine Hut for my king f3
King F - okay
this improves my night I still want to
keep pointing there now I'm more
inclined to play out for because it's
coming with tempo and I could get my
king rolling towards the center hmm no I
don't know if that's right the night is
ready to go in here there's still
another Avenue hmm okay let's do this
looking for D for putting pressure on
the B pond I'm not sure where my knight
wants to go I I know that he he should
improve but I'm not sure where exactly
he should go
let's do that for starters probably has
to come back over here huh maybe I go
like this
staying off of f2 just in the event the
night goes to c5 at least 94 follow up
is not with check I think I like that
idea and I'm thinking rook d2 b8 as
necessary I don't think that this is a
good idea I'm prepared to meet b3 with
c3 and then I could looked up a pressure
on him Wow okay I think I could just
take here Rick is getting active but
this is a strong night he can't be
attacked so easily by the rooks and who
else is going to attack him
rook d2 king f1 Bishop takes pawn I have
night tix I don't have to take with the
king
okay they're in a very restricted
position now King here no they don't
have to do that let's welcome some
exchanges I'm good coordination here I'm
off upon and this still is a target
pretty big time edge as well and also
this is a pinned piece there's no
getting out of it either because they
he's defended I was just questioning I
wonder okay they resigned
it's wondering if I had that move the B
for one move sooner now I didn't cuz
only after the rook exchange was the
rook on c8 unprotected so where do we
stand I have to and okay top here is up
there with 12 who doesn't have a fire
okay let's try a welcome Oh widow arm
now we have an exchange okay let's go
Queenie
- immediately okay let's just get on
with some counseling
how about rook here I'm opposite the
Queen how bad can that be I feel like I
want to insert a flight square move
before I even declare my dark square
bishop that's dropping upon that's not
just any pawn either now these guys are
very very weakened they need to castle
I'm totally for a queen exchange being
up some material and I'm going to get my
pawn here if these guys are exchanged
I'll have b3 this is a move I wanted to
play anyhow a5 a4 is the only direction
I could see black oh and meanwhile I
think my knight does well without this
pawn around I'm looking to take
advantage of this square so I could win
some more material now and let's go for
a pin
yes now we're going to take here and
then I'm winning a ruck next because
this move is hitting with an attack
against the knight and the rook so this
one's falling
yeah they dismissed that the b7 pond was
hanging and it's pretty
for the important
- the whole queenside they resigned back
to tournament I now have fire again with
this rocket start
you win that first game that's why it is
so important okay 41 minutes left a
Malloy
let's try D 5 and reply to d4
why not okay a bit of a modest start for
white with d4 and then III and also c3
they could try to take and hang on to
him I guess that's what they're going
for I'm just gonna play with a 6 and
look to develop and recapture they're
gonna hang out to it it's officially a
gambit I'll look to take advantage of
the weaknesses that are created with b4
they're not doing that
this is weakened this is weakened and
now I'm better no material not down any
material and I have something to point
out and I should probably stay pointed
at it
ya see no reason to pull the bishop off
of this diagonal it's really strong not
because it eyes IV 3 but one day once
counseled it's pinned so I'll look to
maintain my dark square Bishop right
here I think I it's sensible to just get
the nitrite out okay
I could take here and now just improve
my night position threatening Queen h4
there's a lot of holes all these squares
are holes within White's position they
missed this idea g3 I can take taking
advantage of this pin threatening and
discovery now winning some material and
let's try to let's keep the Queen on
board and let's just get the H file open
up I'd like to have rook h1 for me I
could take the pond but I want to use
this as like a little lever pawn takes
rook h1 I really don't have to react to
this Knight dropping in here it's only
one piece I guess this but then I could
start advancing I guess we'll take
pun and then think about pushing
or even capturing actually yeah let's
still keep the Queens on board bishop
there I could take here I just want to
push him I don't feel a need to castle
here
Bishop check bishop block is no good
because of the Queen coming down here
with check later
is this a square can rely upon wits my
king it is let's do that now Bishop
checks the night is out of the ballgame
I'm just looking to run for a touchdown
here
nothing nothing more okay I guess at
this point I can exchange Queens because
there's not going to be anyone stopping
the H pond so I'll be netting some more
material I could just keep pushing
getting another Queen in just a moment
they resigned back to tournament my
first four pointer I have eight
farmville is up there the I lost my
first game against farmville and then
he's been on a berserk streak nineteen
with fire fourteen thirteen twelve less
than forty zanbato is up there as well
and they still playing yeah most likely
looks like a royal apes' position there
before it is let's see what let's see
what will senior will is gonna throw at
me mmm okay let's try royal up has the
exchange variation threatening five now
I have the fish
here but I have the structure hmm
let's go Queenie to first flying very
fast I don't think this night is oh I
guess it's all right there I don't see
why cannot just take here I'm winning
that e5 on two moves away before my
rooks are connected can win another pawn
but I don't want that I'm gonna opt for
some more development instead
I feel like I helped a bishop out a
little bit this is good enough focusing
on some development this this is a bit
annoying if the bishop goes back here to
break the pin then I'll do this take the
bishop and then push take advantage of
the pin let's keep the pin
I may even sacrifice if g5 it would be a
little bit careful of Queen d4 if he's
not around to watch over d4 no this is
probably unnecessary to try and do some
sacrifice okay now I could take here and
then go here to damage the structure and
this is a whole in one day and maybe
this moment right here is when I should
run into f5 yeah I probably shouldn't
feel a need to castle even
yeah and dropping some stuff no okay I'm
up two minor pieces let's keep the
bishop pointing at the heart let's just
put a halt to any a pawn move and
improve the Queen get the rook involved
a 1 2 e1 be fine to see this this would
be a great home for my knight
I just want to back up that's why I
played b3 this is the plan 9 c4 rotate
to d1 f4 f5 to extra piece
and I have very good squares for them
Queen I want to get rid of the Queen
position don't really cares so much
about this I have Forks but it's
unnecessary I just want to get on with
attacking the King here these extra
pieces let's keep pushing take here
don't want them f 6 e 6 I guess I could
take him ok they resigned back to
tournament I have 12 still on fire still
in berserk mode and also in a game he
just picked up a piece there day 5
24:17 1635 minutes call it tsunami of
prawns next opponent all right let's try
g6 Bishop g7 you know let's try this
little flexible setup for pawns attack
all right let's get the night out and
get castled I want to have this position
open up really soon let's start with C 5
and on d5 d6 when I open the position up
and probably this let's just undermine
the center undermine the support for
that I could kick their night away at
any moment
Oh also this is weakened right now so I
have some tactic yes starting with this
make the night move and then take a very
valuable center pawn however the order
in which I do is important I don't want
to do this because it takes and then
takes take your first and then I could
take on this square and then take the
rook now this is there something better
I don't think so
I'm gonna go straight in for it okay so
now I could have a connected past pawn
let's do that
and I could always get my rook active
like this if challenged with Bishop e4
and they're losing material I could take
that rook to I want them feel like I
don't even want the rook let's just
develop now at least when this capture
comes about I get to take and have a
tempo
feel like this is worth a real lot
instead of going for the win of material
I'm almost certain that's what the
computer would do to just take the
material but there's certainly something
in that of this past pond who has very
nice support I feel like in a way he's a
connected past pond let's get this rig
working Knight d4 is a nice landing spot
possibilities for sacrifices against the
bishop and pins okay I see no reason to
hold off on dropping my knight in there
I open up two pieces here with that last
move two pieces are brought to life
Knight takes Knight check bishop here as
a threat I don't have to react to this
that I probably do have to react to
though that one certainly has my
attention because of pawn takes and then
f7 is under fire
I could play Queen f6 Queen h5 there's
h6 let's see yeah I feel like this is a
fine move
still that passed pawn in fact c2 at
some point can be a nice deflection or
maybe even net some material 109 okay
now I think I could go in for this and
then get some material on the Queen
still looking at this stuff
while the night as well the Queen King
called too far has to make a move and
defend the night or maybe even throw a
counterpunch here okay I could just take
the Queen and they are only noticing
that right now yeah I thought I was just
double-checking that there wasn't
anything fancy with their pawn takes
pawn check already at 16 maybe try for
an Enzo Indian a BOGO Indian its e3
mm-hmm prepare to fiend kiddo keep
control over 84 I could take the 94 I
could take the knight and then win 83
I'll take and then play 94 looking to
hunt down their dark square Bishop okay
hitting the Queen and the Bishop I'm
going to take that out
taking it the night is interesting wanna
have an e5 push one day I'd like to have
a pond restrict these two nice clamping
effect they're playing me for I want to
play e5 let's get this move in first I'm
gonna keep it fluid in the center I got
what I wanted here a little bit some
success I don't know how well I do to
hold off on well let's play h6 first
let's see yeah let's see where their
king goes I don't want to commit yet
let's do this now because it does pack a
punch this is a beautiful square I'm
threatening a fork multiple Forks
I think the bishop has to back up does
target this guy now and probably push
through here next with b5 maybe they're
not going to be able to castle at all
Knight d2 super strong piece I also have
to be careful of some tactics now if the
if there's some frontal pressure file
pressure on my knight
my queen goes elsewhere
this is a possible tactic okay I'm
winning upon and now I can look to drop
in here numb comfortable castling out of
five or I could even focus my attention
on this side of the board an interesting
move let's come over here yeah let's do
this for starters and also Queen h4
seems very active I'm okay with giving
up my Bishop for the night
this guy is enormous on c5 yeah let's
just make something active Queen h4 g3
white square weaknesses
let's stay active he takes pawn I could
take here and be on the Queen I could do
this backup takes takes takes Queen III
check really active post for my queen
okay can I not just get away with taking
here I think I could me just double
check some possibilities for the Queen
and Bishop coming to life over here
without this pawn around could also
consider this but Knight here is
annoying I think takes fun if Queen here
I do this I like my
too much I don't even want to allow this
let's just take and now I could actually
do this move because there's this pin
you really can't put a value on this
night he's far from three he's putting a
lock down this night connected with the
pawn alone his a giant clamp on the
whole queenside twenty five minutes and
change farmville has been on a tear
hasn't slipped up I don't think less
than twenty just take their welcome a
queen exchange yeah sure I could take
with the night
think the pond is fine though take here
and take the pond no okay
probably just improve the king now right
they're gonna lose on time anyhow that's
putting into anymore pawn move I just
want to eliminate this guy okay now
these guys are rolling it's a fork I
almost missed that and just trade down
okay still got some material no
stalemates no stalemates they're down on
time back to tournament I guess I
misspoke oh no he did have fire but he
did slip up he got nicked one oh is this
the game you lost I guess it is so he
isn't in a game I mean we're gonna get
paired up again so Lu foe took him out I
guess
way to go uh-huh have another chance
let's see what we get
ah we've played this line in bullet
chests multiple times first time in
blitz
okay let's come all the way back
I'm gonna go just a single step I want
to keep my epon around I want to see
that Bishop commit he's not budging okay
let's
going on my little journey here
I have to be prepared to meet exactly
that move with this I think at least hmm
what's wrong with playing deform
let's go deform I could play night h2 to
watch over this
I feel like I should be taking let's
take my dark square bishop needs to play
Bishop III is when I'm looking at I'd
like to get a piece to c5 mm-hmm field
spots to do this to have my queen also
help out defending against g4 otherwise
I could easily easily easily get
squashed
all right let's throw a punch at the
rook for starters Oh
so this feels pretty active let's do it
hitting the night how do they get the h5
move in now Bishop c5 b4 Bishop b3
there's also Knight g4 striking at h6
I'd like to see the bishop move before I
play Knight g4 I don't want to be able
to I don't want the bishop to allow
excuse me I don't want the move Bishop
takes Knight to happen in one move I
want to make it I'd like to invest some
more time I think b4 is an interesting
move just to undermine this square if I
get this in I'm happy let's do this
first I know I said I wanted to do this
but you could do it on the next move I
want to make sure that this square that
they can't make use of that let's do
this now Queens not getting trapped as
she may be she is actually huh be be
careful let's can test the D file a
little bit I think this is an idea yeah
let's go here a little back in for
earth I really don't want to draw fairly
even on the clock okay my connection
just went and I hope I'm back streaming
okay I think I need to challenge this
bishop I think this is blacks best piece
and then I want to sneak in on the light
squares I have a safer shelter they
could exchange and play f3 if you could
say in the chat to refresh for other
viewers 43 seconds can I get some
confirmation that chat is that are we
back live
now let's go here
maybe a bit too fast
and actually it's ugly structure but I
think it's a good one oh they're really
allowing that interesting gotta stop
this advance I want to play against
their Bishop King physician
you held them in
bind here also down on time
keep improving my King maybe go grab a
paan
why not try for it right actually
there's no reason to not just enter like
this their night is actually soon to be
forced to capture and I could just keep
entering hmm let's keep pushing keep
pushing and let's improve my king and
this is a one ending with the bishop
superior king physician grab that pond
and then just win this he's running home
yeah we got Bishop d6 I right there down
on time
Oh there was a tough one
we both had very good pieces and it was
tough too and I know it was tough game
I was trying to identify who where were
the best pieces for my opponent I
thought that the LightSquared Bishop was
because then it allows me to enter in on
the light squares
let's try Knight f6
I guess g6 okay I rarely play this inter
Greenfeld land I'm at 24
let's get c5 in immediately and Queen a5
could have an ending soon Queen d2
capture hmm I think - oh why did I do
that I could have just taken here and
then won the bishop
silly very very very silly I was focused
too much I was focused too much I'm just
breaking up those ponds this could have
already been a one-game capturing here
and picking up the bishop although I
guess they could have blocked to
challenge that night night d4 is a move
I'm fine with this
it's targets III he's a weak link how
dark square weaknesses but they don't
have a dark square bishop or a knight
that could make use of these Queen here
yeah but beyond that there isn't
anything scoop him up now up one pawn
already have a flight square let's get
this guy working and what next rook c1
let's go here defend throw a punch and
I'm welcome to a queen exchange it's I'm
up upon and I'll have an active rook and
that's good enough for me
so next phase is let's get these guys
going
let's clamp down on these advances can
improve my King just a single step I
want to get my King on e5 let's do it
now I want to cut the King off my Rick
belongs on a3
oh why did I allow this actually it's
okay I think I could get my pawn far
enough advanced this was a better try
one King and pawn ending
got a past fun and extra it's improve
the King well he's going after this guy
I'm going after these guys here we go
I won't like to give up this square so I
could sneak in its got to move sometime
there we go there's no fancy white pawn
moves to create a passed pawn take stuff
and run
and we got 14 minutes left in the
tournament and he resigned back to
tournament we go I'm in fourth 28 with
fire okay I get a couple more games in
yep two more games in so let's see what
we do with these next two maybe get
eight more points let's see Oh always a
tough player a good friend chest friend
always a tough battle okay going with
something ultra solid here I think the
majority of our games are 5 oh not
certain on that let's get a flight
Square in I want to see this capture
before he moves this is useful
waiting game hmm eventually I'll commit
uh I can actually consider that move I'm
gonna get on with this they're gonna get
b5 in let's come all the way back you
could probably play c5 right away huh
hmm okay
yeah I didn't have time for b4 and some
clamping down stuff
Bishop f3 it's a really strong piece
just like in the my last game against
farmville there LightSquared Bishop was
the best piece and I feel that it's also
the light square bishop that's the best
piece here I guess they could throw some
heat on the d4 pawn I think it's a
liability to play with an isolated pawn
let's take with the Queen okay
let's go here 95
95 is probably a good move
for its 95 Queen f4 I don't know if I
want to give up my darks for a bishop
let's try to play with it still on I
guess they could do this huh you know a
little back and forth do not want to
draw I don't believe I'm getting trapped
g6 then I can't go here I can rely upon
that for at least for a moment they have
some weaknesses they're gonna kick me
away but at least my queen is secure for
a moment
okay next phase get to the open file oh
just insisting on the screen trade
yes I can't really avoid it you take me
though that's the plan you take me it's
still a very strong piece no you know
what in this ending I don't think it's
as it's so strong
then it feels pretty active let's do it
a little time edge a nibble
exceeded e1 he's gotta go I can't
tolerate that guy
and probably now is the time to make
that Queen exchange huh
okay
right here I guess my pawns are soon to
be split opposite color bishops though
if they take here I want to keep
pressure in this pawn that's why I went
here instead of the seventh interesting
I don't think that that's the right move
though I'm gonna display my pawns but
opposite color bishops I'll be able to
control these squares no let's prepare
for this
I think he's going down anyhow okay
they're lucky that's covered otherwise I
have check and then here uh-huh
that would have been nice
I still think that he belongs here
bishop glued on this square it's a
really nice let's combat there light
square bishop for starters no I want to
make sure the F pawn doesn't move ever
okay they're ready to move the pond
okay if the h-file opens up I could made
on the h8 square ooh they're allowing
this my king gets to sneak in the rook
is restricted let's take away some light
squares the rook still can't move
they're ready to take that pawn with
check even on time King over here
g7 get my rook on the seventh and pick
him up we'll try it why not you bug you
keep pressure on that guy I might repeat
a little bit they're gonna come right
back over to have three oh I learned off
the hook I totally missed that the king
could escape bishop here's a threat my
king could enter like this oh it's
coming
down to the wire here ah the kingfish
that's about it
you
No why did I go there
that wasn't I wasn't trying for some
mouse trick oh my god
clearly a draw a rat race
ah man man man ugliness I have 32 I'm
looking to get second zanbato he
withdrew well if I get this one I think
I'll be able to sneak into second I'm
not catching uh Farmville he's got too
much
he's got 45 ah
what a game what a game in-betweener
wits check okay they're out of that
which worries me the same time they're
opposite my rook let's drop back here
Knight takes I'm going to take with the
b-pawn Bishop takes I'm taking with the
Queen and I'm looking for h4 night h5
night g3 formate we might have it it's a
long way off but it's an idea to be
familiar with this this is a pretty
serious threat I'm close to executing it
believe it or not
can still drop in here clean is a strong
piece this is pretty serious now night
g3 because of my control over this
diagonal dum it's a making to threat by
the way the night has to play here I
think you know now what I would like to
have happen is the night be removed like
this takes and then here can I really
pull that off I feel like I can
f-five takes takes f4
how can I make this work this is to cave
Manish I'm never gonna get get the night
I think this is sensible because
yeah I think I could actually do this
and then I'm opening up the Queen to see
here
ah I'm chewing up a lot of time as well
okay well let's do this
that has to take wow you know I
definitely had to do that and now can I
still maybe smash through somehow on the
bishop maybe better to just challenge
the Queen I don't know I'm really close
to weaving some kind of a mate maybe
also f6 just to get rid of this guy
playing without any of my pieces except
my queen hmm yeah that's pretty good
oh let's start with this some mating
ideas on h2 which is probably a good
reply Bishop d3 Queen Bishop d3 rookie 4
maybe I could do this right because
there's also a pin here f5 and then I
have my queen stable he's a really dumb
piece isn't he but at least he has this
purposeful defense should there be any
pressure on the D file if there was a
knight around and the knight was able to
arrive here and he was close to doing
that that this could be big trouble for
me but I think this is a nice timely
move pawn takes pawn I take the Queen
they missed that their queen is hanging
whoops okay
I'm gonna play it out a little bit easy
to lose track with the emphasis on those
two pieces being cleared out
step up finally get this guy working
rook up and then over let's crack at
this my Rick wants to play and he still
wants to play getting over the h-file
soon
that should be it I mean two three they
resigned back to tournament and ooh so
much for podium land huh a couple other
guys came up there
those are pretty long game 38 38 36 is
where I'm at to back 54 wits fire one
minute 35 another pairing whether it be
another pairing
maybe we'll see
let's see
you
you
yeah I guess I guess that's gonna do it
1 minute 7 seconds yeah I'm not gonna
get paired up again that's gonna do it
under a minute let's have a look at
Farmville finishing out the tournament
he went no he would didn't go in berserk
would say right here ooh it's down a lot
of material he's gonna get some back but
and it's even showing the time here okay
34 seconds I don't think that this
feature was always here 30 seconds in
the tournament clock yeah white is up a
piece no not so 37 seconds to convert
this now the Knights defending the rook
36 seconds plenty of time and the night
is picked up did he resign just in time
he might have resigned before it did he
get that game in that won't count
I think it did has a little bit of a
buzzer bees buzzer beater okay 59 very
nice top score there farmville zanbato
DM and JJ MD and I was out just a hair
with 36 45 players in all see page 2 3 4
& 5 already a nice little tournament of
44 good games Oh
all right
you